Probably the most entertaining app is the Comic serial app
It generates a series of comic books. Based
on your prompt here, let's say. Make a
About Rude parakeets that
will not stop. this idea. Make sure that
we have models selected. These are the deep. Must
be the First on the list for whatever reason. We
will select. Flash 3. Gemini
3 Flash preview and for the image model, let's use
Gemini 1 Flash image preview. Save
our model settings. And the reason it's called Comic Serial
is because you can generate a first comic book series
comic book, which includes many frames. We will do that
in a second, but then afterwards you can generate sequels
and you can keep generating sequels as desired. The final
step is then to render the comic book into an
HTML format which uses the same images. It just gives
it a Nice HTML framing. But
first, we'll monitor the generation of the comic book itself
have a Sketch of a script. And
then it goes into character generation. The first
step that it does when generating comics is to generate
Character reference images. These are then used when it's
rendering the comics themselves. In order
to achieve And now we're on to the actual
page generation. Again, you can monitor this in real time
It ends with even a nice little fourth wall joke
Great. So now that that generation has completed and my
paracretes agree. It is time to render the comic book
This renders the HTML structure that will How is
the comic since the Basic comic book framing
is Somewhat basic. This
should only take a moment. Here
we go. Let's open this in a new tab and
preview it. We've got our character reference images and Now
a much more attractive presentation with the textual dialogue
alongside also. And
that is the comic book generator. I hope you enjoy
it.